But before I let you go, I want you to
address one thing. And uh and I just the
absurdity of it. Some of the internet
rumors that somehow Israel is behind the
Charlie Kirk um murder. And you know, I
don't believe it for one second, but uh
I want you to, you know, make a
statement.
>> Do not forget to check out cindi.com.
Brothers and sisters, one of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims with the
recent boycott that's going on with many
brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers and sisters, you guys
know I've been supporting Cindi.com.
I've been wearing their stuff long, long
time ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love
their clothing, brothers and sisters.
It's exactly what I I like.
Alhamdulillah, when it comes to fitness,
training, jogging, just general wear
when I'm praying. I don't need to worry
about my back showing. Buy it for your
family members, your your uncles, your
brothers, your husbands, whoever it is.
Inshallah, brother and sisters. Buy it
for yourself. Inshallah. It'sam
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys can see me well. None of
the team members are here today. I'm
operating the camera by myself. Subhan
Allah. As you guys know, yesterday I
done a video about um why I believe that
Israel and Mossad took out Charlie Kirk.
Obviously, now there's speculations of
the culprit, the peru the perpetrator
who is we can see it on camera. There
are some footage which you can see in
we're going to watch in a minute. Him
coming down the roof. Uh he's got
obviously they can see he's got a cap
on. He's got an American flag shirt on
uh from his footprints. They're seen
that he was wearing Converse. And
straight after that, we're going to go
to an interview of um uh the these um
Christian Zionists. Yes. Who uh one of
the news anchors, I think they're called
Newsmax interview and asking him the
question that there are rumors on the
internet. Yes. My video amongst many
that many people cuz people are woken up
to this now. They're not buying this
bull crap. Obvious Muslims, Muslim,
Muslim. No, no, no. Those days are over.
False attacks that you killed Charlie
Kirk. Look what he had to say. Look how
he stutters. Let's first watch the video
in of the suspect that uh the suspect
>> upper building. He's going to come out
on the right, move to this far right
corner.
As he does, he's going to climb off the
edge and then drop down to the ground.
As he did that, he left some palm
impressions. Um there's some smudges in
some places we're looking to collect
DNA. There's a shoe imprint where we
believe the suspect is clearly
identified as wearing Converse tennis
shoes again. We'll replay that again.
>> So guys, so far you can see that man
does not look like a Muslim at all. And
I'm so sorry Tommy Robinson the far
right
apos the puss we tweasel the Christian
you know the fake Christian accepted
Islam so sorry the disappointment in
that you know and and there's still a
potential there still there might be
hope you know it's not that they care
about uh the child's death it's oh you
know there might you know it might be
Muslim it's not a Muslim a damn it man
the disappointment now we're going to
come straight to the video in then I'm
going to play a powerful video because
there's still a discussion about um
mourning etc look we need to answer And
put it very very clearly and I I I stand
by this as well. Yeah. Okay. We do not
ask like I said before the the Charlie
Kirk with his evil speech that he said
it was I'm veently against his speech
like 100%. Somebody who is pro genocide
get out of here man. However I'll make
this crystal clear again. We they are
not our teachers. Char is not my
teacher. The messenger of Allah in the
Quran and Islam is my teacher. We are
not taught to kill his men and children.
Okay for that matter. We are not taught
that at all. So I want to make it clear.
We do not ask anyone to be killed, shot
like that. Never. At the same time, we
will not be mourning his death. Let's
make that categorically clear. Okay?
There is no shame in that at all. Okay?
Because it's hypocrisy and double
standards which I'm going to do another
video of no logic, Mr. Triangle Square
man. Okay? Doesn't know what a flipping
triangle is, how many sides he has.
Okay? In another video where he's
crying. He's crying. We're going to
discuss that in another video. But let's
go to this video where Benjamin
Netanyahu is talking and our Muslim
position. Everyone who has a heart, it's
not just Muslim position. We do not
condone the killing. Neither will we be
mourning the death of Charlie Kirk.
Neither will we be doing that. Okay. I
feel sorry for his kids and his
children. They're innocent. His kids and
his wife, they're innocent in this
matter. His wife, again, we don't know
who's spoiling, but anyways. But yeah,
let's go to the video in shall here we
go.
>> But before I let you go, I want you to
address one thing. And and I've just the
absurdity of it. Some of the internet
rumors that somehow Israel is behind the
Charlie Kirk um murder. And you know, I
don't believe it for one second, but uh
I want you to, you know, make a
statement. It's so absurd.
>> That's insane. That's insane. Israel uh
also changes the uh the orbit of the
moon. Israel pushes the sun. I mean, the
whole thing is it's not only insane.
It's I think it's so absurd, so stupid.
It's so stupid and so ridiculous. You
can't believe that people are
>> Why is it stupid and ridiculous, you
Satan? Why is it stupid and ridiculous?
Did you guys not attack the US Liberty
ship? USS Liberty? Yes. The the JFK
killings? Yes. When he wanted to make um
Apac a foreign um agent. Yes. Do you
think this is like coincidences? 911 and
the five dancing Zionists and they were
connected to Mossad. Epstein Islands
funded by Mossad. Do you think it's
farfetched? Do you think people are
stupid? Do you think people are actually
stupid? Yes. Let's see. Look at how how
he stutters more.
>> Saying that they just found the
perpetrator. They'll get to the bottom
of this, but uh uh they they go, you
know, they have no limits.
>> They did not find the perpetrator. Why
is this speaking so certainty? They
haven't found the perpetrator. They they
have kind of identified. They haven't
found him yet.
>> When you hate Jews, uh when you hate the
Jewish state, they're willing to say
anything uh and promote all these absurd
absurd rumors. Uh and by the way,
they're willing to to kill us all the
time. I mean, that's what they're doing.
And you know over the centuries when
when Jews especially in the middle ages
the horrific middle ages
>> I don't understand why is he not coming
and mentioning I mean if I was him if I
was accused of something like that and
and argue if I was him and Charlie Kirk
was a venomous supporter of us and
recently started to question us etc.
I'll say stuff like you know what say
why would we kill him why would we kill
him when and it's not even a discussion
because the thing is yeah they know they
have the capability of killing them cuz
it's not even father's way it's that we
have done we've never done such thing in
our how could you like imagine I am not
known to do such things but he's saying
no we haven't meaning we have the
ability but we did not do it yes okay I
would have come and say you know what
look he's been supporting us etc what
reason would we have when somebody like
him is supporting us to kill him yeah
nothing he stutters etc But let's carry
on. And now he's going back to
anti-semitism, you know, etc. You
they're basically saying, and we know
what the Jewish people went through.
Yes, we understand that's that's it was
horrendous. But you can't just keep
using that to justify your horrors. You
can't do the same thing. Oh, that's what
we went through. Now we're going to do
the same to others. No.
>> Uh the worst things were said about Jews
you can possibly believe. We were
poisoning the wells. We were drinking
the blood of Christian children. You
name it. I mean, these things that
continued actually up to the Holocaust.
The Nazis said the same thing. You know,
we're carrying vermin. Uh we're
spreading disease. And people believed
it and every time they believed that
this was a prelude to a greater and
greater massacre culminating with the
the worst massacre of them all the
Holocaust. Well, since then we've
learned a when people spread these lies
about us, prepare yourself for the
assault. And uh you know they're trying
to delegitimize the state of Israel.
Charlie Kirk said to me that he wrote me
this detail letter. You have to fight
the slander. These untruths, these
vilifications have consequences. And he
was right. But I'll tell you one thing.
We're fighting on the battlefield
against the terrorists and winning. And
he was fighting on the battlefield of
ideas. And I think he was winning. He
was going to win. That's why they shot
him. I hope they don't silence him. I
don't think people will give into these
ridiculous ridiculous lies.
>> And not only that, um he wanted to
invite uh Charlie Kirk. Why would you in
the middle of a war and Charlie Kirk has
been speaking? Even you saw Ben
Shapiro's face. He was shocked when
Charlie start questioning things and he
was talking against the slowly slowly
changing his mind against the Zionist
regime. Why would you invite him? Why
would you invite someone like him? Yes.
Why would you invite him knowing that
he's speaking out against Israel? You
know what's happened?
you know, you are behind all of these
false attacks from 9/11 to JFK uh
killing um uh
to the 91 91 JFK killing USS Liberty.
Yes, you have a look, you have a track
record, my friend. You have a track
record and you have every capability and
ability to do that. And you know very
well you call that shot. you know very
well and the whole internet knows days
gone are the days of Muslims done this
and Muslims done that I won't be
surprised if this attacker comes out and
says yeah my name is Abdman Rashid or
something like that okay you can see
clearly guys the fact that this question
has even been asked to him shows that
people are waking up to the evil of
Zionist people are waking up and they're
going to carry on waking up they blamed
Muslims for for far too long killed
millions of innocent Muslims and where
the barbarians Yes. Where the
barbarians?
I'm going to leave it at that guys
inshallah and I'll make you make your
decision which is clear who is behind
all this evil. And like can said if
today they are killing the guards and
children and making the guards and
children orphans tomorrow they will do
it to the Americans and they have
started off with Charlie Kirk. They have
started off with Charlie Kirk and they
killed him. It's as simple as that
brother and sisters. Till next time.